المساهمات حب التعلم والمرونه اسمي ساره
سعيد باوزير
مهندسه واكاديميه
[موسيقى]
في مرحله في حياتي كنت احب اسوي اكثر من
شيء اسهم في اكثر من شيء مثلا اروح اتطوع
اسوي
هل هذا صحيح هل انه الشخص اللي يعمل اشياء
كثيره
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد اي شيء من هذه الاشياء
فبحثت مع نفسي سالت نفسي شو الاشياء اللي
انا حاب اساويها وليش وشو اهميتها عندي
وبعدين بعد فتره طبعا استمرت على
نظامي والاشياء اللي تستهويني اشارك فيها
لكن بعد فتره اكتشفت تكمله المثل اجاكم
فولتس اذا ماستر اوف 9
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لبناء شخصيتي ما كانت في نقطه
تحول واحده كانت في اا مجموعه نقاط تحول
اهمها انها مرحله
المدرسه انها مرحله الجامعه التخرج من
البكالوريوس
ماجستير
مرحله
العمل
كل مرحله من هذه المراحل في نقطه تحول همم
اول تقريبا عشر سنوات من بدايه حياتك انت
همم
[موسيقى]
امي وابوي والعيله كلها فينك كثير
مشاركه
الالعاب بعد المدرسه العب الكره كره القدم
كره السله
وطبعا شعور الطفل الوحيد شعور حلو بس
بعدين لما تصير انت ال الثاني يكون عندك
ضغط انه انت لازم تكون المسائل الاعلى
للاخوه الصغار
امي وابوي هم
الاشخاص اللي يدعموني اكثر شايفه حياتي
لما كنت ارغب اروح التطوع انا وانا صغيره
كنت شويه شاي يعني
ابوي يروح معك بعدين لما صار عندي
يعني العائله كلها
في حياتي هو اداره الوقت
كيف اقسم وقتي بجزء للدراسه جزء للاهل
وجزء للشغف او للوقت اللي اقضي مثلا العاب
او اسويه هوايات فكان هذا اكبر اكبر تحدي
يمكن
يعني اواجه التحدي بس طبعا مع الوقت صار
عندي ادوات تغلب فيها عليها التحدي حلميني
اخر الدكتوره من احد اكبر الجامعات حول
العالم في تخصص الهندسه
الطبيه الحيويه
الهندسه الطبيه الحيويه
والنيجرني وحبيت اني اكمل فيه وارجع وادرس
[موسيقى]
طلابي اللي لما ادرسهم احس بالانجاز لما
اشوف المعلومات
[موسيقى]
الهندسه الطبيه الحيويه
شعوري ان المعلومه واصله حسسني بالانجاز
وبالفرح